in the last video I showed you that the
definition of efficiency ADA is the work
that we do given the amount of heat we
are given to work with and we show that
for an engine that could also be
rewritten as 1 minus q2 over q1
essentially the heat that we output from
our heat engine divided by or 1 minus
the heat we output from our engine
divided by the amount of heat we input
from our engine now we apply this
formula to a Carnot cycle and we said
hey for a Carnot engine we could get an
efficiency we get an efficiency of this
so I let me write this here so the
efficiency for a Carnot so ADA for
Carnot is 1 minus t2 over t1 to get this
result I we had to use the fact that we
were dealing with the Carnot cycle to
use you know we were moving along these
isotherms and I was able to take the
natural log of home and and do all of
that and I was able to get this for the
efficiency of a Carnot engine and let me
be very clear this is the efficiency
that can only be attained by a Carnot
engine the other definitions of
efficiency so when I just defined
efficiency is equal to the work
performed divided by the heat and we
call it the heat input or when I defined
it as when I define it as the change the
net the net heat let me put it that the
net heat in so q1 minus q2 over q1 this
applies to all heat engines this is true
for all heat engines including including
the Carnot engines and a heat engine is
an engine that operates on heat I
probably should have said that a while
ago and you know these this engine that
I made this Carnot engine is definitely
a engine that is operating on heat
because it's taking heat here and later
it releases the heat down here the cycle
just shows what's happening to that
engine I just want to make that
distinction to the engine is the actual
physical thing the cycle just describes
what's happening to it so with that said
I said that this is only true for a
Carnot for a Carnot heat engine now what
I'm about to embark on and I don't know
if I'm going to finish it in this video
it might take into the next video to do
it properly is to show you that if we're
operating a heat engine between two
tempered
sources so I have my hot temperature
source I'll call that th 40 hot and I
have some it's an H not an N it's
transferring some heat q1 and some other
heat is coming out at q2 at q2 and I'm
performing some work and then q2 and
then my my other cold temperature
reservoir I'll call that T cold is down
here and that's where I'm releasing the
heat to I'm going to show over the next
few videos that the most efficient the
most efficient engine is this
theoretical Carnot engine that no engine
can get more efficient than this so this
is a Carnot engine this is the most
efficient engine the most efficient or
this is the ideal where nothing is lost
well I'll go into that in a more detail
no engine can get more efficient than
this then this Carnot heat engine so to
get there to prove it to you I'm gonna
I'm just gonna play with the Carnot
engine a little bit just to show you
some of the tools that it has at its
disposal so one of the things let me
just draw a PV diagram it's P that's V
let's see whoops wrong tool P and V P
and V and the Carnot cycle we've done so
far we kind of always moved in one
direction we had our isothermal
expansion it went something like it went
something like that that was isothermal
then we had our adiabatic expansion and
the whole time we were going in that
direction then we had our adiabatic
expansion and it went like that then we
had our isothermal contraction it went
something like this
it went something like that and then we
had our adiabatic contraction to get to
where we were to begin with so then we
went back like that and the whole time
we went in this kind of clockwise
direction we went in the clockwise
direction and we took in heat up here
because we were doing work we took in
heat to keep our temperature constant
and then we released heat here to keep
our temperature from going up from q2
and so if I were to draw another draw
this another way I could like well I
just did one like that but let me draw
it like this
I could also depict it like this where
that's my engine this is my hot
reservoir let me put this is t1 t1 is up
here it transferred q1 to my Carnot
engine my Carnot engine did some work
did some work and then left over or
transferred into my cold reservoir t2 it
transferred q2 this is another way of
depicting what went on in this Carnot
cycle and here I've actually drawn the
engine now one of the tools I want to
show you is that and is that this is a
reversible reaction or or that we can
take this and go the other way around
and it's dependent upon an assumption
that I threw out a long time ago so when
I first drew these I kind of introduced
you to the idea of a quasi-static
process quasi quasi static and quasi
static just means look you do it really
slowly so that you can always say that
you're pretty enough close enough to
equilibrium that you're your macro state
variables are always defined and that
was the whole justification for dealing
with pebbles like this but instead of
just doing it wholesale instead of just
moving all the pebbles and just getting
to this state from A to B kind of
jumping I wanted to do it gradually so
that I would be defined at every point
in between
that's what quasi static did for us and
when I actually made the video on
quasi-static processes I said you know
quasi-static processes for the most part
are reversible and sometimes I used I
use the words interchangeably now by
definition our theoretical Carnot cycle
is said to be not only is it quasi
static but it is also reversible which
means at any point in time let's say
we've moved we've moved a couple of
pebbles and we gotten we've gotten right
here if we want to if we're in the mood
we can add some pebbles back and just
follow this right back to where we were
that's what reversible means now I mean
it means you can reverse something now
what what what do we what has to be
ideal about the system
in order for that to be true well it
means that there was no that with that
the actual movement of our of our piston
of this movable ceiling that it
shouldn't have any friction because if
some of the heat is lost to friction
then when we go back we would have lost
some of our heat some heat would have
been destroyed just going from one state
forward and back so the assumption that
we have to make for the Carnot cycle is
that or the assumption we have to make
an order for the Carnot cycle to be
reversible is that it's frictionless
frictionless frictionless so the Carnot
heat engine this theoretical engine is a
frictionless engine which is
theoretically impossible to be
completely frictionless to be but well
we'll talk more about that in the future
so I want it so if you have a completely
frictionless engine and it's
quasi-static it's also reversible so if
we want to do it reversible what does
that mean it means I could start in this
state my state a that I've labeled
before but instead of going around that
way I could go around the other way so
what I could do first is I could I could
adiabatically expand first so let me do
let me do it maybe let me let me redraw
it so I do it the other way so I could
reverse this reaction and it would
happen the exact same way and that's an
artifact of that I'm always in
equilibrium and that my system is
frictionless that I don't lose energy
just going back and forth so I could
start at state a here and then I could
adiabatically contract adiabatic
contraction would look something like
this and I'll get to that state then
then I can isothermally expand so I'm
going like this then I can isotherm
eclis expand and as isotherm eclis
expand let me so I'm going like this ice
I'm all along an isotherm I'm doing some
isothermic expansion so in this case I'm
doing work but I'm doing worse work
isotherm eclis right at some at some
cold isotherm I'll call it a let's call
it t - right just like this was T - so
in this case if I'm if I'm expanding and
I'm staying at t2 and I'm sitting on top
of my t2 reservoir
heat is coming he this area under the
curve the work I'm doing is the heat
added this is q2 and that is given to me
by by my t2 reservoir so everything is
going in Reverse that's the whole idea
that I adiabatic Li contract I can
adiabatically contract like that and
then I isothermic Li contract then I
isothermic Li contract like that to get
back where I start when isothermic Li
contract what's happening work is being
done to me so now all of this area over
here will be negative and in order to
keep my temperature constant I have to
release heat so I'm releasing heat but
I'm doing it at a high temperature so
I'm releasing it into my t1 reservoir so
it's the exact same thing is it happened
before but since when I go in a reverse
direction I'm actually some work is
being applied so now if when you look at
it this way when you figure out all the
areas the area in here will actually be
negative and the reason why I'm saying
that is because the positive work values
are going to be this this sir this is
going to be the positive what I'm doing
in blue right here and the negative work
values are going to be what I'm will be
all of this stuff so if you wanted to
figure out the total work done it's
gonna be negative so what's happening if
I run the Carnot cycle in Reverse so
let's call it I'll call it the Carnot
refrigerator or no and that's not what I
wanted to do I'll call it Carnot reverse
but it's handy that are also stands for
a refrigerator Carnot this is the Carnot
engine it does work by using heat by by
by taking advantage of the heat the
difference between this hot you could
have you this as a tea hot and the tea
cold now a Carnot a reverse Carnot
engine or maybe we call it a Carnot
refrigerator does the opposite that's
exactly what I just drew over here what
it does is it starts with the cold body
it starts with the cold body I'll call
that tea cold or t2 it takes some
smaller amount of heat
it takes some smaller amount of heat
from the cold body from the cold body
some work has to be input into this
system in order to do this and then it
puts more heat kind of you could have a
kind of use a combination of this work
and this and this heat taken from the
cold body and it gives it to the warm
body sorry this is q2 and it gives it q1
so everything just happens completely in
Reverse and that's just a byproduct of
this is reversible so I can just go and
I can do this this is the way we went
before when we're an engine if we want
to be a a refrigerator we go the other
direction and everything just gets
reversed and I want you to really
understand that this is doable that this
is there's no there's nothing wrong with
this you might say hey doesn't this defy
the second law of thermodynamics we're
going from we're taking heat from a cold
body to a warm body and my answer will
be the same thing I said on my entropy
videos I said well no we're applying
some work this is a refrigerator so some
work has to be done in order to do this
and whatever object that is doing the
work maybe some in the case of your
refrigerator it's a compressor that is
adding more entropy to the system than
the entropy that's being destroyed or
more entropy to the universe than the
entropy that's being destroyed by our
refrigerator so this does not defy the
second law of thermodynamics now I want
to make another I want to make another
point about the Carnot engine let me
take the reverse Carnot engine I'm going
to call it a real Carnot refrigerator so
if we take that and this is really just
more math than anything else if we take
that if we're taking if we're taking in
q2 adding in some work and producing q1
we can scale this up arbitrarily we can
scale this up arbitrarily if we take two
times if we take let's say we take x
times if we take x times q2 in and we do
and we put in x times W in then we're
going to put x times q1 into our top
reservoir and that makes sense because
these are just arbitrary numbers so if
we do if we have for example if we have
two Carnot engines in parallel you can
just kind of view those view that is
that whole thing is two Carnot engines
doing it together so all of these would
be twos if we had three car
engines doing it together all of those
would be three and you could just view
them as one collective engine now with
that said I think I've laid the
framework for for at least the the ideas
that led us to a let us show that the
Carnot engine is the most efficient
engine that's abled that can be produced
and given that the Carnot engines
efficiency is this and we're going to
prove that it's the most efficient
engine this becomes the upper bound on
efficiency for any engine that anybody
can or will ever make and I'll do I'll
kind of do the crowning touch in the
next video